foreign
we're gonna go to Robert and Boise uh
let's go Robert how's it going with you
that's good
how can we help today
okay so
um I had a tsp question all right there
are actually two questions about the
Thrift Savings Plan
um I retired last December congrats from
um thank you I worked at the border
patrol for 21 years wow but
since since then
um because of covid and because of uh
backlogs of people retiring I haven't
got my full pension yet it's been almost
almost 12 months so I'm getting a
partial so right now between child
support and rent
I'm coming out at zero so I'm trying not
to dip into my tsp
at all if I can help it because it's
it's taking a hit over the last year or
so so it's drastically reduced and then
I've got friends who are taking that PSP
and going to like a private someone I
don't know like linking Financial or
someone where they can still play with
it and make some money
I gotta just kind of sitting there doing
nothing right now
okay so question questions are uh do I
dip into it because I got to pay some
bills I'm I'm going to bet further and
further using credit cards and
everything
waiting for the government to come
through with my full pension and the
second part is do I shift it over to a
private company where I can possibly
make money on it
well number one on my tsp I I never wait
on the government to do anything in my
life because you're going to be waiting
a long time as you know so number one
I'm cutting up the cards and the just
debt is not going to be an option and uh
if we need to adjust the budget if we
need to go get a get some work right now
even though we're retired I'm gonna do
that to stop the bleeding number two I
wouldn't just jump out of the tsp and go
play with it elsewhere in the private
sector I don't think that's why he's
easier either now you can if you need
some of it to live right now that's okay
but I would be working with a financial
advisor you can connect with a
smartvester pro those are the ones that
we vet over at ramseysolutions.com we've
got some in the Boise area who can walk
you through the best decision to make
with that chunk of money that you have
in the tsp if it's worth moving
somewhere else if you can make more
elsewhere
um but I would not just go cash it out
to survive because you're not stopping
the actual Behavior that's causing us to
to feel this pain
right right
okay I'm sorry you're going through this
man that's tough to go I work 21 years
Ken and the government said they were
going to take care of me and here we are
and they're kicking the can down the
road that frustrates me to no end and I
hate that you may have to go back to
work for a little bit to make ends meet
but man that credit card is a rubber
crutch it's not setting up for Success
it's not a blessing in your life cut it
up get on a budget use that debit card
and we hope that you win in retirement
and live your best life thanks for the
comment